casada o soltera,
blanca o negra.
Puedes ser republicana, demócrata o independiente.
Lo escuché de muchas mujeres:
oficiales de policía,
miembros de nuestro ejército,
asistentes financieras,
actrices, ingenieras, abogadas,
banqueras, contadoras, profesoras...
periodistas.
El acoso sexual resulta que
no va de sexo,
sino de poder,
y sobre lo que alguien hace
para tratar de quitarte tu poder.
Y estoy aquí hoy
para alentarte a que sepas que puedes recuperar ese poder.
(Aplausos)
El 6 de julio de 2016
salté de un acantilado yo sola.
Fue el momento más aterrador de mi vida;
una decisión insoportable de tomar.
Caí en un abismo sola,
sin saber lo que habría debajo.
Pero luego, algo milagroso comenzó a suceder.
Miles de mujeres comenzaron a acercarse a mí
para compartir sus propias historias de dolor, agonía y vergüenza.
Me dijeron que me convertí en su voz,
ellas no tenían voz.
Y, de repente, me di cuenta de que incluso en el siglo XXI,
toda mujer todavía tiene una historia.
Como Joyce,
una supervisora de azafata
cuyo jefe, en reuniones todos los días,
le explicaba el porno que había visto la noche anterior
mientras dibujaba penes en su bloc de notas.
Ella fue a quejarse.
La llamaron "loca" y la despidieron.
Como a Joanne, banquera de Wall Street,
a quien sus colegas masculinos la decían esa palabra inmunda con P todos los días.
Ella se quejó.
Etiquetada como alborotadora,
nunca más hizo negocio alguno en Wall Street.
Como Elizabeth, una oficial del ejército.
Sus subordinados masculinos agitaban billetes de un dólar en su cara,
y decían: "¡Baila para mí!"
Y cuando fue a quejarse a un comandante,
él dijo: "¿Qué? ¿Solo un dólar?
¡Vales al menos 5 o 10!
Después de leer,
responder a todas
y llorar por todos estos correos electrónicos,
me di cuenta de que tenía mucho trabajo por hacer.
Aquí están los hechos sorprendentes:
una de cada tres mujeres, que nosotros sepamos,